le fantôme du lendemain 6 ans de façon
récurrente meilleur de vinci au vermont
ainsi pérennité
[Musique]
la scène c'est un des grands tableaux
théâtrale de l'histoire de la peinture
parce que absolument tout le monde est
assis face à nous donc c'est idéal à
copier ses hôtes au théâtre
oui bien aidé son rôle entre le même si
je portais en moi
l'embryon d'une génération nouvelles
dents en lumière
nous devons bien faire comprendre que
j'étais la seule à savoir
avec 1
[Musique]
bon si c'est un diamant avec plusieurs
facettes si on arrête jamais d'en faire
le tour c'est très difficile de faire un
portrait complet vient l'heure de vinci
parce qu'ils ont il est un poète
musicien un ingénieur un peintre un
médecin et tout se finit par former une
personnalité et une idée qui est
extrêmement complexe
moi ça me donne le goût de continuer à
faire des spectacles solos en disant que
c'est peut-être l'occasion pour moi de
montrer différentes facettes qui je suis
mais paradoxe mais aussi de mes
contradictions 2000 différents talent de
mes différentes passions quand j'étais
jeune je lisais beaucoup les livres de
mon grand frère qui avait beaucoup de
livres date émane et je me suis
intéressé
si on veut al'allure particulière un peu
ambigu des modèles de léonard de vinci
c'est beaucoup plus tard abandonnée
quand j'ai commencé à moi même commencé
à dessiner et à peindre à faire de la
mise en scène que je me suis intéressé
plus sérieusement à l'oeuvre de leonard
mince j'ai eu besoin d'apprendre italie
pour des raisons pratiques
c'était essentiel de comprendre
léonard de vinci dans le texte aussi
[Musique]
il entretient une grande passion pour
tout ce qui est machinerie s'intéresse
aux gens non de vinci à la machine comme
un médecin ou un scientifique
s'intéresse au corps humain c'est de
comprendre comment ça fonctionne et
comment faire jaillir la magie de la
machine et ça moi ça sature était une
chose qui attire la curiosité j'ai
lendemain ici et je me suis reconnu
beaucoup danse on m'accuse souvent de
m'intéresser à peut-être un peu trop aux
nouvelles technologies du sommet je me
suis toujours un peu à la manière de
léonard de vinci
une nouvelle technologie c'est comme un
nouveau pot de peinture comme sont à
inventer de nouvelles couleurs pour 10
et aux artistes voilà voici une nouvelle
peinture qu'est ce que vous faites avec
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez exprimer avec
ceux qui pouvaient pas s'est exprimé
avant essaie simplement de vinci faisait
finalement
[Musique]
dans le spectacle co ce qui est
intéressant c'est que il fallait trouver
une d'une manière de créer une scène
plate forme sur laquelle les jeunes
allaient pouvoir performer dans un
environnement qui lui en principe avait
pas de gravité
pourquoi je lance de 26,6 retrouver un
peu dans le spectacle comme c'est qu'il
y avait toute cette machinerie de tout
7,7
toutes ces équations avec laquelle il
fallait faire pour pouvoir réaliser le
spectacle mais avait surtout cette idée
qu on est dans un monde on avoue crée
finalement cosmos où il n'y a pas de
mots il ya pas de boy a pas de si vous
voulez une saint il faut qu'elle arrive
du plancher duo faut que ce soit à la
verticale ce qui fait que tous les
points de vue étaient avantagés le faire
alors fallait essayer de donner au
spectateur le point de vue de tous les
possibles
ce qui a toujours été un petit peu la
manière de penser de leonard de vinci
mais moi je pousserai la chose plus loin
par rapport à las vegas il ya un ordre
ainsi c'est que moi j'ai retrouvé à las
vegas un peu le même esprit
j'imagine qu'à florence à la renaissance
italienne
on se retrouve à vegas ainsi coude à
coude avec les gens les plus
intéressants en ce moment qui crée
l'architecturé la musique et des
chorégraphies des spectacles et je pense
que le lendemain si son grand message
c'est la découverte de la beauté dans
tout on est tous à la recherche de la
beauté c'est maintenant devenir qu'est
ce que c'est la beauté et c'est ça il y
en a deux
[Musique]